what is happening fellow reject nation
reg alba here and it's John Humphrey
overhears or oats studios journey
continues with a volume one edition of
God's Serengeti yeah I know little about
this except for the sharlto copley a
minute yes yeah I saw the thumbnail so
John I mean if you guys watch their
first two reactions you've probably
already heard us say it but just in case
what's telling us to do is it it's okay
if you're this is the first set you're
watching one of these out Studios is the
new experimental film lab created by
Neil Blomkamp and company they
specialize in these experimental sci-fi
films you can check them out on YouTube
on Steam they have a lot of content on
Steam actually if you want to get the
full comprehensive experience you can go
and steam that's also where you can
directly support if you want to $4.99
for at least each of the main shorts you
can access dailies sound stems
behind-the-scenes stuff 3d models if you
want to make your own stuff out of it
you can get involved that way it's
really cool you can check them out on
YouTube Facebook and steam the reason
why we're doing this too is because a
we've got an a lot of requests to go
check out both Studios Volume one alder
all the short films and part four zygote
is coming out today which stars Dakota
Fanning who was actually in his BMW
driver film yeah and also Hosea Pablo
Canty oh we've seen them plenty of
things just look at as IMDB yeah and so
we're really excited for it we've gotten
some pictures to see what it looks like
a front we saw the teasers for its we're
like yeah let's start watching these
because everyone's raving about it
everyone really wants to check it out so
let's do it let's watch part 3 gods
Serengeti this one is the shortest one
of them all the other ones are 20 plus
minutes this one's only 3 minutes and 53
seconds but hey sharlto copley man oh
yeah one of my faves one of my favorite
actors
[Music]
on
[Music]
my back like little days then like Noah
look you animal it's way more than two
never mind is a fun morning okay
some books technicals my taste I like
the chaos and watch past does a good
recipe for black hole there what's going
on over there
give it up second chat doing except
funny Trebek chef in rubbing at six
hours and it'll be bloody shell
fire equipment I didn't say you could do
that I did survive
what are you feeling good in fact mm
probably should be using Ruby please
knock him out
[Music]
and use it in the back into that cave
it's fascinating brain
[Music]
for God's sake what is it now
we believe it's rained out so we forgot
to turn off the drought hey all right
then give it some awesome NZ good yes I
passed be my pleasure
[Music]
dancing into surfing do it again get
this better mom this is the wincle gets
it again
to question miss Blake ha ha ha oh ha ha
listen plague
you
Oh God Wow really on the definition of
experimental shortly hey I wouldn't
describe it as a comedy but this one
ramped up on the humor for me yeah yeah
it's it is kind of a like a dark comedy
comedic look at how God runs plenty yeah
and it already back to my own thoughts
and fantasies I've had before oh yeah
God is just just like a person and we're
just a smaller creation inside of this
person's invention it's a great way to
personify that dude's into the table
like working on his book and then
watching like it just kind of toying
with life and having it play out the way
he wanted to play out what is
fascinating there's always that element
to of like an AI stories but any sort of
like life that I created sort of stories
where like there's a removed from ethics
yeah because he doesn't seem to care
that much disease or you know tormenting
these people in certain ways ya know
they're just a little science projects
as little experiments and I think that's
like what a lot of the theme is of these
oats to do things is what is creation
and experiments if you look at volume
one that's experiments and volume 2 this
creation manifesting from grief and then
this one is how God rules the world and
it's up yeah it is everything I'm really
wondering if these are all connected or
if they're just little short film nerves
yeah do these ones its own idea yeah
yeah
and I'd like to see one of these turned
into a feature film this was really
fascinating to me I wonder if there's a
bigger I hope so I wonder there's a
bigger story in mind to this specific
one than just this if this is a teaser
for something because it's still under
the volume one edition at least I gets
its own distinct thing right now you
know and and I would I would love to see
more of this I mean I just I love
sharlto copley and I think he again he
brings such characterization to this his
God really does it does make you wonder
like he does feel very lived in in the
way that he plays it and it does kind of
have like a you start to think about how
you how you perceive the universe and
how we perceive the universe's attitude
if you were God and use created
everything you probably wouldn't be too
concerned while you're working on a
bunch of other like this is one in a
series of things that you made this is
really interesting even it was first we
know Blomkamp's first religious take how
do you know I guess brevity is the soul
of wit and this is the shortest of them
but it's I like it when he branches into
more comedic territory I mark darkling
comedic do ya there's always something a
little grim at the middle not even God
is controlling it really he just gonna
be making he's give me the order so he's
not even doing a lot of the things yet
but we're doing it the whole thing well
that whole first thing about LaGuerta
they have fire take you away yeah
my creation isn't behaving the way I
wanted it yeah she's kind of like the
the way you would imagine God when
you're kidding no that's what I meant by
hardening back to my own little
fantasies I had when I was younger yeah
the big man upstairs watching no play
out I think it's really interesting that
you know cuz sharlto copley and Neil
Blomkamp are well known duo after the
three feature films that you get with
sharlto copley in a neo Blanc a movie
you would expect maybe okay this is
going to be as a sci-fi Ultimate Alien 1
or something after what you do see it
gives you something completely different
completely on the 109th and say thank
you compared to what you would expect
effort ooh the collaborations they've
already done prior when every time
they've collaborated like he is
completely different things they connect
her every time yeah is is you know kind
of a dweebies almost spineless guy at
first and then the character you played
in Elysium is just an animal and then
chappie is a childhood baby I don't want
he little light
chappie and I know you know we've
discussed our feelings about that movie
before I like that movie a lot i think
his performance as chappie in the mocap
is really under a by patrick and i know
here he's the man in charge the man in
charge he was always is natural yeah
yeah it kind of is kind of having his
little what's the word for it up satire
like I don't want here is a little
satirical commentary you know God might
actually be it's definitely a poking at
the concept of God and religion and and
you know changing the perspective is
always fascinating and so you just
peering in on God study it's really
making me wonder are we just watching
experimental short films or these going
to connect in some way or are we just
wasting our time wondering if they're
going to connect in some way either way
I'm enjoying the ride yeah I'm really
enjoying each one of these like I'll be
impressed if these build up to some kind
of thing that they're all trying to do
back same time hey if there's all their
own individual things I'm kind of down
with that - yeah or might be that it's
really this character of God is the one
in control this whole thing I can see
legacy in linking all back to that at
the end of the day different world
creations that this God keeps on making
and then having different play outs
occur oh yeah I'm you know typically
aliens and firebase different kind of
aliens in raqqa and they had an outer
seeing the creator who's making all this
happen yeah well you know it sets up the
idea of of the world as one that has at
least some loose knot loose boundaries
but you know like in firebase you see
there's that like weird space-time risk
saying that we're not sure exactly what
the nature of that is and that's
something to this sort of further aside
to me like beyond the cool designs
beyond the you know it's easy to get
engrossed by sci-fi but you know I like
actually the variety in the different
shades and tones that we're getting to
be with this and that's partly what
excites me so much is the fact that
things are different they could be
linked that they might not necessarily
be the fact that I can see ways in which
they might fit together but they don't
necessarily have to yeah I think they've
created something that's interesting and
fluid and has the potential to grow and
I'm also interested
you know if people start getting really
involved and you know working with the
the materials and competing equities I
would kill time love to be in one of
these in I don't care what it is
yeah care if it's a background role I
would love to be one of you this is a
dream right here I mean like they're
making it seems like they're just doing
what they want to make and they're
they're pushing boundaries and they're
you know in different you know in tech
and in storytelling and you know in
visual imagery and in ideas like this is
what's exciting to me in terms of like
filmmaking beyond just like the movie
business well it seems like Oats Studios
is exploring humanity is our life
outside of Earth what is the spiritual
life and you see here survival energy
men of men manifestation of energy all
it's like all these different types of
beliefs I feel like all these have
similar themes in short but we do you
think it yeah yeah and then and this was
a nice one to throw into after you know
you have two really big meaty sci-fi
kind of epic you know different but
still very sci-fi and then this one is
kind of sci-fi banana totally he's
totally different way the first couple
and then you know you go online you
watch little infomercials and even
though is there are different still yeah
because those look like actual
commercial yeah those are a bit off the
wall and so yeah with a variety of tones
in the variety of direction they're
headed in like this is this is pretty
magical to me it's also copley really
behaved Maleficent and that is not I use
eggs that makes it does man he's a real
hardcore Henry about everything yeah I
could do his ride ride maybe he's
definitely a part of the Neil Blomkamp's
a-team he was in that too he was I like
that movie dude like 1 to 10 people all
right guys well yeah you can make sure
to go check out the oats studio channel
on YouTube you could catch their videos
on Facebook and you can also go on Steam
you can check out all the stuff that you
can see on YouTube and Facebook and you
can access the bonus content again if
you want to get involved if you want to
support if you want to make something
cool yourself that's the point man now
we're just anxiously waiting for Xavier
to come out and
to get enough time to maybe you know
make something I had a time I would love
to start pulling some of these things
Eli as I'm gonna make a ball or break
acid theories about everything yeah
we'll make a sketch that turns into yeah
Vietnam no film theory to do an episode
hey guys subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell is that
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of Blum house we
finally have a real reject Instagram and
we have a Twitter and of course check
out our patreon patreon comm slash the
real rejects for exclusive perks and
rewards loving the peeps over there woo